اصيب 12 فلسطينيا على الاقل في مخيم عقبه
جبر في مدينه اريحا بجروح خلال اجتياح قوه
الاحتلال المخيم صباح اليوم وقال مستشفى
المدينه الى الاصابات تتراوح بين الخطيره
والمتوسطه بينما نقل اثنان من المصابين
الى مجمع فلسطين الطبي مجمع فلسطين الطبي
في رام الله لخطورته حالتهما وقال الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني انه لا يعلم عدد
الاصابات وطبيعتها لان قوه الاحتلال منع
الطواقم الاسعاف من دخول المخيم وقالت
مصادر الصحفيه فلسطينيه ان الاحتلال يدفع
بتعزيزات عسكريه اضافيه مع تحصن مقاوم
داخل منزل ورفضه تسليم نفسه بينما قال
رئيس اللجنه الشعبيه للمخيم ان الاحتلال
يهدم اجزاء من منزل بعد رفض احد المطلوبين
تسليم نفسه وقال جيش الاحتلال له اعتقل
عشره فلسطينيين في المخيم خلال عمليته
العسكريه تشتبه ان بينهم منافذه عمليه
اطلاق النار على مطعم من المستوطنين عند
مدخل مساطره الموج جنوب اريحا قبل نحو
اسبوع هذا ونشرت منصات فلسطينيه مقطع
فيديو لاعمل تجريف تقوم به جرافه
اسرائيليه في محيط المنزل المحاصر بمخيم
عقبه جبر في اريحا بالضفه الغربيه
صباح اليوم السبت
معنى الان من مخيم عقبه جابر باريحا مراسل
للجزيره سمير ابو شماله ليضعنا في صوره
الوضع هناك تفضل سمير
[موسيقى]
نعم ازدهار نحن الان في داخل حاره
المقايضه في القريبه من السوق المركزي في
داخل مخيم عقبه جبر حيث كشهدت هذه الحاره
وهذه المنطقه والمنازل المحيطه في هذا
المكان عمليه عسكريه مكثفه منذ صباح هذا
اليوم واستمرت لقرابه في اربع ساعات الجيش
الاسرائيلي انسحب من مخيم عقبه جبر واعدم
انتشاره في النقاط العسكريه المحيطه في
بمدينه اريحا نحن ربما تشاهدون على هذا
على الشاشه الان هذا جزء من احد المنازل
الذي كان يحاصرها جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
خلال هذه العمليه وقد اطلق عليها عدد من
الصواريخ المضاده للدروع حيث كان يتضرع
بان بداخل هذا المنزل عدد من المجتمع بهم
في تنفيذي عمليه اطلاق نار عند مستوطنه
الموج قبل نحو اسبوع جيش الاحتلال خلال
هذه العمليه يتحدث عن انه اعتقل اكثر من
عشره فلسطينيين بينهم عائلات فلسطينيه من
يدوي المشتبه بهم في هذه الخليه التي تقول
قوات الاحتلال بينهم قد نفذوا هذا الهجوم
المسلح وقد قامت باعتقالهم ونقلهم الى
مراكز التحقيق
ولتحقيق معهم في المراكز المحيطه والقريبه
من محافظه اريحا المراكز العسكريه
وبالتالي
المواطنون قد هرعوا الى هذا المكان
والمنازل الاخرى ايضا التي تضررت كثيرا
خلال عمليات الهدم والتجريف من قبل
الجرافات العسكريه التي كانت مصاحبه
للدوريات والعمليات العسكريه التي دخلت
وقت احمد مخيم عقبه جبر خلال هذه العمليه
العسكريه وايضا كان هناك عمليه مواجهات قد
اندلعت بين قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
ومواطنين خرجوا للتصدي الى قوات الاحتلال
بعد ان كان هناك نداءات عبر مكبرات
المساجد في داخل المخيم للتصدي لقوات
الاحتلال وقد اسفر ذلك حسب المصادر الطبيه
الفلسطينيه عن اصابه اكثر من عشره
فلسطينيين اصابه اثنتين منهم
خطيره نقلت الى مجمع فلسطين الطبي الى
مدينه رام الله بعد التنسيق مع الصليب
الاحمر الدوري حيث كان هناك منع من قبل
قوات الاحتلال للطواقب الطبيه والاسعاف
الى الدخول داخل مخيم عقبه جبر خلال
النشاط العسكري في داخل هذه المدينه الجيش
الاسرائيلي تحدث بان انه يشتبه بانه قد
اعتقل احد المطلوبين لدى لديه في هذه
العمليه ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه هذه الانباع
غير مؤكده بشكل رسمي من قبل الجيش
الاحتلال ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه لن نتحدث عن
اعتقال اكثر من عشره فلسطينيين مواطنين من
عائلتي لافي وايضا المقيطي وهما التي حصلت
القوات الاحتلال المنزلهما في داخل هذا
المقايي وهناك اضرار اخرى في منازل اخرى
في مكان اخر قد تعرضت ايضا لعمليات هدم
جزئي عند الاسوار الخاصه بهذه المنازل
وبالتالي الجيش الاسرائيلي انسحب من هذا
المكان
وهو يطبق الخناق منذ عده ايام وايضا تعرضت
هذه المدينه التي تعتبر هي اهم المدن
السياحيه في هذا التو للفلسطينيين وخاصه
لمدينه القدس والضفه الغربيه وايضا كان
هناك تعطيل للحياه الاقتصاديه والتجاره
والسياحيه والاجتماعيه خلال الاسبوع
الماضي من خلال تجديد الحصار عليها من
خلال هذه العسكريه على مدينه اريحا من
مخيم عقلي في اريحا مراسله الجزيره سمير
ابو شمله شكرا جزيلا لك